hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome to
the first of one of my many Doctor Who
series 8 q and A's hopefully i'll be
doing these on a regular basis but since
this is my first let's all have a drink
so most of the questions you guys have
about you know what's going to be the
old stuff that they're bringing back and
what's going to be some of the new stuff
that they're going to introduce during
series 8 so i picked 10 of your
questions and there's a special bonus
one just for fun at the end real quick
announcement though since Matt Smith is
officially gone I'll be changing my
channel avatar sometime soon it won't be
Peter Capaldi it'll be a cartoony
version of my face I have absolutely no
idea what its gonna look like but I'm
talking to some of my favorite artists
to figure it out so i'll be sure to keep
you guys updated also because we're
starting to learn things from the set of
series 8 i'm going to start doing videos
for that too so i'll probably do a video
next week explaining some things we've
learned based on the scenes they shot
outside last week be sure to subscribe
to get that alright so let's get started
don't worry I'll be drinking during this
question 1 Ryan Nicholson asks what do
you think about the rumors of an easter
special so there was actually a rumor of
an Easter Special last year when they're
talking about series 8 nothing has been
said about it since and obviously you
think the BBC would spend some time
marketing it if they want to get people
excited about a full hour of a brand new
doctor so I don't think it's going to
happen it's possible that they might do
a webisode it's more likely that we'll
get a regular Christmas special though
question number two veg to bed s asks do
you think we'll see the return of the
master in series 8 and if he were
generates who would you pick to play him
so there haven't been any confirmations
or denials at the Masters coming back
John Simm is still totally capable
playing the role but if he is coming
back and Johnson doesn't want to play
the character anymore some really
awesome choices might be Jason Isaacs
from Harry Potter Dan Stevens from
Downton Abbey or maybe even Idris Elba
that would be totally awesome but I'm
not expecting the character come back
question number 3 Lydia sombreros asks
would you be posed to having an American
actor appear in series 8 I'm totally
open to anyone appearing on the show as
long as they're a good actor and the
characters are interesting the reason
why it's largely a British cast is
because its use in the UK is just for
practical reasons question number four
Jack O'Connor asks if Peter Jackson were
to direct an episode in series 8 what
sort of plot would you have them bring
to life so it's looking less and less
likely that Peter Jackson is actually
going to have any time to direct Doctor
Who
but if he did he would totally have to
do a period piece and something with
some really awesome creatures think of
it as being like Doctor Who Lord of the
Rings or you know like Lord of the
TARDISes or something like that he is a
big fan of Daleks so he could always be
the person to bring Daleks back to
question number five mark brew yet asks
could the similarities with three have
something to do with Tom Baker saying
he'll revisit all phases so you're
talking about the similarities in his
costume honestly I think the revisiting
old faces is just a wink and a nod to
possibilities for future anniversary
specials Tom Baker was really just kind
of seating the idea that they could
bring back old classic doctors you know
old faces who are still alive question
number six Slade x-23 gaming asks do you
think the series 8 episode 1 will have a
new villain or do you think an old
vulnerable return so in the 11th hour
they had two separate races appearing
for the first time at least on camera
there was the attract see and then there
was that mystery villain I don't think
they ever named what the race of that
was so I'm actually guessing it's gonna
be something similar to that question
number 7 tere Davenport asks will
Gallifrey play into the plot yes but
only in the background think of series 8
is having three main types of stories so
the a story will be whatever the new big
villain plot is you know like the
silence during series 6 that'll be like
the a plot the B plot will be the
Gallifrey plot I'm not expecting them to
find Gallifrey or to fix the solution
during series 8 and then the sea plot
that third one will just be the week to
week problems the doctor solves wherever
he ends up going question number eight
Salinas he asks what will River songs
role in series eight be so outs Kingston
did one of her classic spoilers lines
just to tease fans you know wearing a
river song type costume there have been
no confirmations from Steven Moffat or
the BBC that she's going to be featured
though the best theory that I've seen so
far is that her consciousness is
actually stored in the papal mainframe
that we saw during the Christmas special
and she'll get out that way question
number 9 brown coat 48 asks will Capaldi
use Matt Smith sonic so sometimes the
colors just change but typically every
new doctor gets a new sonic so yes Peter
Capaldi for all intents and purposes
will get a new sonic the TARDIS interior
will not change though they spent a
couple million dollars making that one
during the 2012 Christmas special so
then I can do that again anytime soon
think about it this way Peter Capaldi's
outfit will change before the TARDIS
changes again and last one number
this one's a fun one more production
asks do you think that Benedict
Cumberbatch would make a good potential
master so yes absolutely there's no one
I have met who did not think that
Sherlock would make the best version of
the master but just to give you an idea
Benedict Cumberbatch is one of the
busiest actors out there so even if he
was totally down to play the role you
know Johnson didn't want to play it
again he probably wouldn't be able to do
it just for scheduling reasons it took
them two years to make Sherlock series 3
just because Benedict Cumberbatch and
Martin Freeman we're shooting so many
movies that's how busy is thank you so
much for submitting your questions guys
this is a lot of fun hopefully I'll do
this on a regular basis I might not do a
QA every week but my next Doctor Who
video will be a production related video
I might also do a video for my top five
or top 10 picks for a new master even if
he doesn't appear in the new series be
sure to subscribe to get it I'm also
doing an arrow Q&A tonight you can click
here to get that and you can click here
to get my reactions to Peter Capaldi's
new outfit thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight high
fives